our fred peter king that's another
reason why I'm back pleased to be back
here because Peter King is joining us
from NBC sports for football Morning
America how are you Peter
how are you I'm hanging in there man I'm
hanging in there let's get right to it
Peter I gave you the floor on the
passing of Don Shula what's the first
memory or first item you thought of when
you heard that news about 90 year old
Don Shula passing away earlier on Monday
faked spike you want to keep going that
New York spike there huh I love it
thanks buddy yeah you did I covered I
cut I covered that game okay you know
with the Meadowlands and I just thought
it was a a lot of that is cool in some
way to cool tribute to Don Shula because
I think one of the things about Shula
that I really appreciated is how he
empowered the people who worked for him
I think he you know if you if you were
to sort of look at a legacy treat that
Don Shula had it was that you know the
coaches on his staff the players on his
team you know always knew that that the
coach had had their backs and I think he
empowered people you know from Bill arns
burger on down over the years
I mean Madhu their job to the best of
their abilities and whether it be you
know a coach who came up with something
innovative whether it be a player like
Dan Marino knowing that you know he had
been empowered to to do the right thing
to be a thinking person on the field I
think that's a part of Shula that that
I'll always appreciate I think the one
other thing is Manny did this for a long
time surgeon I mean he he or John F
Kennedy was president when he coached
his first game and he coached for 33
years
there aren't a lot of people who can do
that and also by the way he had two
losing seasons he never ever in 33 years
had a bottom two out team the worst
record he had in his life was six and
ten and so I just I think there's so
much to admire about the guys very very
principled guy and there's a lot of
people who will miss Don Shula and I'm
one of them
well I mean is there anything that you
normally talk about innovation innovate
or anything on that front for the
winningest coach in the history of the
National Football League
honestly rich I really think that so
much of and I think this cannot be this
doesn't sound like a real innovative
thing but I think if you if you were to
ask the people who work for Don Shula
the the fact that they were so they felt
so empowered you know there aren't a lot
of head coaches who will you know really
good head coaches I Andy Reed really
comes to mind you know he's always
pushing his assistant coaches and he's
all he's always giving them tasks and
you know guys who work for Andy Reid
love working for Andy Reid and I think
it's the same thing with Don Shula you
know they felt like when they went out
there that he had their back and I I
think that is something that that's one
of the first things I uh you know I'll
always think about him they eat who's
really a good head coach to work for the
thing that yeah it's funny you mentioned
fake spike because again I'm from New
York City I'm a fan from since birth
that one hurt a lot but another Shula
moment was when the Jets had Freeman
McNeill right Richard Todd is the AFC
Championship game they're going down in
the Orange Bowl
and and Shula just let it rain there
that just let it rain just he just did
not yeah tarp out there he knew that the
running game for the Jets was coming and
then AJ Dewey I think he's still picking
off Richard Todd
that game in that AFC championship game
and that the gamesmanship that Shula
also took part in yeah is something that
was kind of next level Peter yeah I
always I always thought that and and it
isn't it isn't just because in thirty
three years coaching he only had two
losing seasons which is absolutely
phenomenal
but I've also I've also thought of him
that he you talk about those little
edges that that he would get you know
there's a guy like Al Davis you know you
would always think of Al as one of those
guys you know he'd do whatever he could
to get an edge you know and a lot of it
maybe he would try to get an edge by
going over the line a little bit the
difference I think between shul and so
many coaches you know who who were in
his league is the Don Shula really
viewed honor is something that was
really important to him and you know all
the over the years when I when I covered
him and that was kind of early and my
national football writing career you
know the the the early 90s every
experience I had with them was just so
incredibly solid and memorable for just
the the thought that you know he would
always do the right thing he'd always
say the right thing and I just thought
it was a really honorable stand-up guy
it's very very good to the people who
did our jobs too
I really had a high high regard for
Peter King here on the Rich Eisen show
and I've got Shuler's longtime friend
and somebody who chronicled his career
hank goldberg joining me later on on the
Rich Eisen show in this very hour Peter
I want to hit you on some news from over
the weekend the true Biscay
I guess non one-button no pickup for the
fifth year of his contract was something
I guess the the writing was all over the
wall
Foles --is acquisition what do you make
of this do you think this is true bisque
'yes last year in Chicago it's all gonna
be up to him hey you know first of all
he's gonna have to win the job at some
point he's gonna have to outplay Nick
Foles and if he does that and he plays
and he's a top 10 or 12 quarterback the
Bears will sign them now we all think
that that's not likely so most likely
yes I would say this is probably his
last year there but again rich it is in
his hands it has been in his hands for
the first three years of his tenure as a
bear and it's not too late for Mitchell
to Biscay to reclaim the long term
starting quarterback job with the Bears
but now there just isn't the kind of
support for him that there always was in
his first three years it was always we
don't care how he plays he's our guy and
I'm exaggerating there of course they
carry early plays right but he was going
to be their guy regardless and now he's
not their guy regardless so he's gonna
have to show that he can be a winning
playoff quarterback for the Bears to
keep on beyond this year now I look part
of the reason why I do this well is not
at all to try and suppose about people's
job security really that's that's not
why I get into it but sometimes it is a
necessary thing to bring up the the
general manager Ryan pace how does he
draft somebody that high and the two
others he doesn't draft go on to do what
they've been doing and still be able to
look at management and say let's try
Foles and if it doesn't work out let's
try somebody else and still be the guy
to try something else
Peter he might not be you know I think
this is a very very important year for
for Ryan paces future now you know look
it's we can sit here and forecast or
whatever we want to forecast but this is
this is going to be it's going to be
very evident at the end of this year
whether mr. Biscay should continue with
the bears and whether Ryan pace should
continue with the bears and so it's one
of those things that and and I don't
mean I don't mean this in any sort of
that's the best way to put it I don't
mean this in any sort of well Ryan pace
is walking the plank right now but when
you've had six years I think this is a
sixth year if I'm not mistaken and you
know if after six years you look at the
general manager of your team and you
don't see a long term starting
quarterback and you don't see solutions
at most of the positions on the team
you're probably going to make a change
so I think the Ryan pace you know this
is obviously a very big year for the
Bears and it's also big year for pace
Peter King here on the rich eyes and
show how would you term the Dalton
signing in in Dallas there's many
different ways there's an upgrade at the
position there is insurance policy
there's insurance policy in case your
current quarterback doesn't sign on the
dotted line I mean how would you make of
the Dalton signing in the Metroplex
Peter I thought it was brilliant me too
and I thought it was brilliant for a
couple of reasons number one if he
doesn't play what are they out three or
four million bucks right they have
bought the best insurance policy that he
Andy Dalton will play this year it's the
best backup quarterback in the NFL and
he might have to be more than that and
if he is and you're the Dallas Cowboys
you could win 11 games if you're the
Cowboys playing Andy doll
there's no doubt in my mind but you know
rich there's one other there's one other
factor here that nobody is really think
you know but I
sort of immediately I want you to you
know imagine what football is going to
be like in 2020 and part of the reality
of football if it's played is that
players I would think I would think are
going to be getting tested every week
for kovat 19 what happens if your
starting quarterback one week that's
positive
I feel pretty sure there's going to be a
rule that whether it's Patrick mahomes
or Mitchell true biscuit that's positive
you got to sit for two weeks and you
can't have any contact with anybody on
your team
so I'm just asking this logical question
what happens if one day starting
quarterback of the Dallas quarterbacks
dak Prescott test positive for Kovac 19
then he's got to sit for two weeks and
Andy doll has got a play now you say oh
my god that's that's a long shot well it
is a long shot but are you telling me
that the 16 hundred and ninety six
players on active rosters in the NFL
this year if a full season is played do
you think none of them are going to test
positive for kovat 19 or my work that's
it that's a that's a silly pipe dream no
I know that so so I'm imagining too I
mean I haven't even thought of us for
you to bring this up
you'd have to probably keep your
quarterback separate right because you
can't just have everybody in the same
quarterback room if that happens because
then you'd have to you know wanting the
whole depth dry right nobody nobody
nobody nobody knows nobody knows there's
to these questions you know I mean you
know you can't if you know I think that
would be a bad thing for your football
team sure if you say oh by the way
Patrick mahomes and Chad Henne I think
he's the backup there is Patrick mahomes
Chad Henne and whoever shape our guys
are not are not going to be in the
locker room this year they're all
dressing in across the in another part
of the building I mean I mean you're
gonna have to treat everybody I
I don't I don't even know exactly but
these are the kind of things that we
just don't know right now but I would
doubt that they would set some players
on a team apart from others Peter King
NBC Sports on the Rich Eisen show so
where does this leave cam I mean you
read all these reports that cams not
coming out you know not playing this
year if it's not for a starting role
there's no starting roles left unless
unless Jacksonville decides it means it
doesn't make any sense in my opinion
right now for Cam Newton to sign with
anybody I don't know why he would if I
were Cam Newton I would just wait until
late August September maybe even October
who really needs a quarterback 32
quarterbacks are not starting every game
this year so if I'm Cam Newton I'm
sitting back there bide my time waiting
until somebody needs somebody and then
I'm right writing in on my white horse
to be a starting quarterback in the NFL
now maybe maybe you could argue he ought
to sign with Jacksonville but I don't
know that I want to sign in Jacksonville
either how ignominiously be if a healthy
2015 Most Valuable Player 30 or 31 years
old whatever he is mmm he's holding a
clipboard and Gardner Minshew is playing
that's why to me if I'm Cam Newton I'm
not signing anywhere until a clear
starting opportunity opens up last one
for you Peter's schedules supposed to
come out this week you know by all
accounts certainly what I'm hearing -
I'm gonna get a full 17 week schedule
placed in front of me to host a schedule
release show later on this week are you
hearing about anything at a top left or
a top right-hand drawer for the
Commissioner upstairs from where he did
his drafting that that will be prepared
by the scheduling folks from Howard Katz
and the rest I think the to kind of the
two big factors that you ought to be
looking for I think
is for the ability of the NFL to easily
pivot in the event that something goes
wrong first of all I don't I disagree
with releasing the schedule this week
there's no need to do it it's not going
to just start creating a bunch of
Commerce people aren't going to start
you know you know planning road trips
and buying plane tickets and buying
tickets to games I mean normally that's
why you put out a schedule in April it's
a it's a kind of a marker in the road
for you to really start looking at okay
here the games are going through this
year and and all this other stuff I mean
who's planning that now you don't even
know if any fans are going to the games
in in September and maybe all through
the year so I would look for that the
other the other thing I might look for
rich is for one part of the schedule to
maybe be portable let's say the first
two or four weeks of the season that
that if the NFL decides to start the
start the season on let's say September
24th instead of September 10th or
started you know like in week five
instead of in week one that you would
then take the first two or four weeks of
the season and just simply transfer it
to the month of January and and so I
think both those things kind of make
sense to do but this is a strange year
you know and as I wrote today everybody
needs to get used to the fact that there
are going to be some things that are
going to be uncomfortable and unfair
what happens if some municipality or
some state says we will not have any
large gatherings of people and that
includes 250 people in a football
stadium to play a game of football so
you know those are the kind of things
that everybody in my opinion just needs
to get used to maybe none of them happen
but maybe there's quite a bit of them
that happen and I think there's going to
be going to be some things that could
very well be even unfair to some teams
maybe one or two teams won't be able to
play all their games at home this year
so you know and I think everybody should
just sigh take a deep breath and say hey
it's one year only so let's just be of
good cheer be of good spirit not
complain about everything and just say
hey if we really want football to exist
we're gonna have to deal with some
things this year that are very unusual
Peter I say I second that emotion I say
plus one but there's always still going
to be Twitter though right Peter thanks
the time love your column and today
especially just as must-read as ever
thanks for the call
as always Peter thanks so much rich
creepy you got a at Peter underscore
King on Twitter NBC sports.com pro
football talk comm to check out football
morning in America
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here